Next we move onto the link layer. If every link between
computers were a dedicated permanent point to point connection, then most of
us decided that two machines should
communicate it would be relatively straightforward
to arrange for them to do so. The challenges here are mostly
solved by breaking up larger chunks of data into more manageable
chunks and putting them inside a frame. Which in addition to the
data payload, would contain some metadata, its length for instance. And probably
some kind of check zone as well to see if the data
was corrupted in transmission. The situation becomes much more
interesting when multiple nodes all share the same medium. Think
of the cable line that carries the internet traffic in
your neighborhood. In that case, we have multiple nodes, the
modems in your houses, all connected to the same wire.
This is called a bus topology. Actually, the original ethernet
had this topology, with all the cables all connected to
a common hub, making it look like a start topology.
In reality, the hub would simply relay whatever signal it
got to all the other nodes effectively making all the
cables one medium. In terms of physical hardware this is
attractive because we don't have to run wires between every pair
of machines on the local network. It does however mean
that messages themselves have to specify who they are for and
who sent them. In the case of ethernet on a
local area network like a home, office or a server cluster,
nics are usually identified through a unique 48 bit MAC
address. MAC standing for media access control. If you have
a router or a modem at home you can probably
find the MAC address printed on the box. On a Unix-like
machine, you can find your MAC address of your network
interfaces with ifconfig than pipe it out to grep for ether.
The MAC source and MAC destination have designated spots in
the Ethernet frame. When the frame is sent through the medium,
all the nodes will receive it. But only the one whose MAC
address matches the frame destination should
pay attention. The rest simply ignore it.